back in 1903's the great train robbery
you could easily spot the bad guy he's
the one wearing a black hat
but modern filmmakers have made it more
difficult to identify mystery villains
dropping small clues throughout the
story for viewers to piece together
before the big reveal
the most recent example of this is
marvel's one division
we probably should have figured out this
twist as soon as agnes walked through
the front door
but identifying a surprise villain
requires knowing
exactly where to look and when to listen
the greatest trick
the devil ever pulled was convincing the
world
he didn't exist warning spoilers ahead
in one division agnes is immediately
established as the overly friendly
neighbor
so we should be suspicious of her right
away because the first thing to think
about when searching for a villain
is to focus on anyone who seems like
they are definitely
not the bad guy they might even be
portrayed as a victim
these characters are often too nice like
agnes
or too weak like mr orange who's
bleeding to death early on
in reservoir dogs in the most drastic
case the villain is even presumed
dead i think the trick to portraying
villains
has to be that you've got to change up
things as often as possible
that's jonathan koontz a professor of
american film
history at the ucla school of theater
film and television
your audiences are pretty villain
literate at this time they've seen a lot
of movies and they know a lot of the
tricks that people can pull and they're
going to be pretty alert
for example alfred hitchcock is famous
for crafting his villains as charismatic
seemingly good regular people a lot of
times
he creates connections between his
villains and his heroes
so sometimes it's kind of difficult to
tell them apart and you see this trend
over and over again in hollywood is the
suspect wearing a white hat
like the sheriff in hot fuzz or william
in westworld
then they are probably going to be
wearing a black hat by the end of the
story
or take a look at ozzy mandius in
watchmen and
captain dudley liam smith in la
confidential
both are authority figures who we're
supposed to trust
these are the types of characters who
often turn out to be the villain
it's become a tale as old as time in
disney and
pixar too there's the nice old teddy
bear lotso
in toy story 3 who smells like
strawberries
and anna's seemingly perfect prince
boyfriend hans in frozen this technique
of subverting traditional villains
only works however if you have a red
herring villain
because there still needs to be plenty
of conflict up until the big reveal
take hayward in one division while he's
definitely a villain
all our attention is focused on the bad
things he's done and is doing to wanda
directing our attention away from the
clues that would lead us to suspect
agnes of anything treacherous but you'll
notice that
lying to the audience is a definite
no-no as hitchcock learned in the film
stage fright
this 1950 movie opened with a false
flashback by the twist villain
and audiences were famously frustrated
because it felt like hitchcock lied to
them
so now filmmakers rely on the art of
omission
they're not lying but they're not
telling the whole truth either
you see this with one division during
the catchy agatha all along reveal
here we learned that specific key scenes
were framed to avoid showing what agnes
was doing at the time
purposefully leaving her out of the shot
so the second thing to look out for
is how a show is framed or how a scene
is edited
in this scene in psycho when marion
meets norman bates
the camera is positioned behind norman
to emphasize him as a threat
sometimes we see angles of him where
he's not simply
a nice skinny friendly guy but he seems
a little bit more looming and menacing
and in the usual suspects when kaiser
soze is mentioned in the hospital
the camera immediately cuts to a shot of
verbal they're literally telling us
whose true identity is
twice these little winks to the viewer
are only there if you look for them
especially since viewers don't normally
think about what's happening off camera
but as we see in one division what
characters are doing off to the side
does matter take this scene where agnes
is the only one who finds wanda's dog
sparky
later we learn she didn't just find him
she actually
killed him
[Laughter]
which brings us to the third giveaway to
look out for the kick the dog moment
obvious villains will have their kick
the dog moment out in the open
but with surprise villains it might be
happening when and where we aren't
looking in the usual suspects verbal is
the one
who shoots saul in the forehead which
surprises everyone else since verbal is
portrayed as the weakest of the bunch
in psycho it's even more subtle swapping
out a dog for taxidermied birds on the
walls at the bates motel
particularly this owl positioned like
it's about to
pounce on its victim sitting across from
norman these moments hint at a villain's
lack of empathy
and in this case even at norman's dead
preserved mother later in the movie
in wandavision there are also multiple
visual clues like this
placed throughout the season to hint at
agnes's true identity
agatha to piece the puzzle together you
have to pay close attention to the mizon
sen
or everything in the frame the props the
background clues
and even the costume design agnes is
always wearing some combination of
purple
and green colors that have been used to
code villains throughout comic book
history
heroes on the other hand usually wear
red and blue
agnes always wears the same brooch with
her outfits
which eagle-eyed fans might recognize as
the same one
agatha wears in the comics sometimes the
costume easter eggs are even more in
your face
she dresses as a literal witch on
halloween
backgrounds are also telling especially
any items purposely visible
just beyond the character reservoir dogs
is famous for its many
orange colored easter eggs sprinkled
throughout the film
hinting at mr orange as the rat
often the easter eggs appear as art on
the wall
in get out this image in chris's
apartment symbolizes rose and her
family's true intent with chris and this
painting in psycho is called susanna and
the elders
it shows a woman bathing who is attacked
by a group of men
directly foreshadowing the infamous
shower scene
and easter eggs can also be props in
alien
ash is shown drinking milk a drink of
choice for many villains
and one that also foreshadows his milky
white android blood
there are also some props in the usual
suspects that hint that kaiser soze
is verbal when he tries to light a
cigarette with his good arm
he knocks the lighter to the ground he
also gets the same gold lighter back
from the police when he leaves the
interrogation
if you look carefully at this scene
verbal accidentally uses his weak arm to
push back on the cop
it seems like he certainly notices his
mistake but did you
timing like this is everything every
time agnes
appears on screen she is there for a
good reason
because there are no coincidences in
screenwriting
when wanda stumbles upon the helicopter
drone agnes appears in the street
look it's the star of the show
and she distracts vision while wanda is
talking to geraldine inside the house
surprise villains also don't make
decisions unless they somehow
further their agenda or hide their
identity like ash and alien ash doesn't
care about the crew
his orders are just to bring the alien
back alive
so he's the one who suggests they
investigate the mysterious transmission
he ignores warnings from ripley and
eventually lets the infected cane
into the hatch even though it's
dangerous and in get out
rose is the one who suggests she and
chris go for a walk
conveniently right as her father is
about to start the bingo auction to see
who will get to buy chris's body
but identifying a villain isn't just
about what you see
sometimes it's about what you hear as
well agnes
certainly reveals a lot when she speaks
the devil's in the details bev
that's not the only place he is
ultimately if you decode what she's
saying
you can see a lot of witch-like comments
in her seemingly ordinary sentences
i'm wanda wanda charm
i actually did bite a kid once dialogue
queues are a
big villain telltale even shakespeare's
villains would say they were
outright evil how am i then a villain in
unbreakable the main villain elijah
accidentally gives himself away
when he says that villains are typically
drawn with disproportionately large
heads
if you look at his reflection in the
glass his own head is distorted to look
much bigger than normal it's even more
telling when characters who are
typically silent
speak up in the opening scene of
reservoir dogs all of the characters are
chatty except
one mr orange but when he does say
something
he's ratting on mr pink for not paying
his tip who didn't throw in
mr pink mr pace our first major clue
that he is the rat in more subtle cases
music can also be used like in get out
listen to the song when rose is buying
pastries and heading over to chris's
apartment
[Applause]
the lyrics literally warn you that she
is out to get him
[Music]
you don't always need a song lyric to
spell it out for you sometimes you just
need to break down a character's name
[Music]
in one division agnes is actually a
portmanteau of her real name
agatha harkness in incredibles 2 the
surprise villain is winston dever's
sister
evelyn once you say her full name out
loud evil endeavor
you realize it wasn't much of a surprise
at all and the usual suspects
wouldn't have had much of a twist ending
if you actually translated the name of
the villain
kaiser souza is derived from the turkish
phrase
soze bomac meaning to drown in words
kevin spacey's character's name is
verbal
and early on in the film he plainly
tells us
people say i talk too much yeah i was
just gonna tell you to shut up
but knowing what to look for in a
surprise villain can also
ruin a tv show or movie and switching
black and white hats can only be used so
much
in each decade it seems the filmmakers
kind of have to up the ante a little bit
one division certainly plays with all
these traditional surprise villain
tropes
but agatha's twist is more than just a
classic evil reveal
even though wanda created the show
agatha was the one
directing it since the beginning you
have to come up with something
new that no one's ever seen before a
twist that no one's ever seen before
and i killed sparky too
[Laughter]
[Music]